[Musique]
les experts le disent la marche le vélo
et la course à pied ça reste important
en période de confinement mais quelle
balises en termes de distance on doit au
juste respecté il ya beaucoup de
confusion autour de la question vous
avez été nombreux à nous soumettre cette
étude devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a affirmé qu'il faudrait
garder une distance d'au moins dix
mètres des coureurs et de 20 mètres des
cyclistes pour éviter d'être infecté par
le nouveau coronavirus selon les
spécialistes consultés par ma collègue
bouchra wathiq cette étude comporte des
limites
les chercheurs européens à l'origine de
l'étude ont modélisé la propagation de
gouttelettes émises par une personne qui
marche qui courent et qui roule à vélo
selon la simulation informatique de ces
chercheurs il faudrait se tenir à au
moins cinq mètres de distance d'une
personne qui marche rapidement à dix
mètres de distance d'une personne qui
courent et à 20 mètres de distance d'une
personne qui roule à vélo pour éviter de
se recevoir des gouttelettes mais
allons-y avec les nuances maintenant
d'abord cette étude n'a pas été encore
publiée dans une revue scientifique n'a
donc pas été révisé par d'autres
chercheurs
ensuite ces auteurs sont des experts en
aérodynamique des ingénieurs mais pas en
virologie
ils n'ont donc pas étudie la teneur
virale des gouttelettes c'est à dire la
quantité de virus qu'elle contienne une
information cruciale pour déterminer le
risque de contagion
c'est simple plus les gouttelettes son
petit moins leur charge virale est
significative
ensuite il est bon de savoir que le
nouveau corps d'un virus ne se propage
pas à travers des micro particules en
suspension dans l'air mais plutôt par de
plus grosses gouttelettes qui retombe
plus rapidement au sol que les
particules en aérosol autre fait à noter
les chercheurs n'ont pas tenu compte des
facteurs environnementaux comme la force
et la direction du vent
face aux critiques les chercheurs ont
reconnu les limites de leurs études tout
en spécifiant qu'il ne tire pas de
conclusion quant aux risques d'infection
alors maintenant que tout ça est dit
vous vous demandez sûrement qu'est ce
qu'on fait les spécialistes consultés
par ma collègue suggère de garder deux
mètres de distance
même en ce qui concerne les coureurs et
les cyclistes
en même temps si vous êtes capable de
garder une plus grande distance c'est
mieux par mesure préventive tout
simplement pour consulter l'article de
bouchra wathiq à ce sujet
rendez vous sur notre site web n'hésitez
pas adhérer à notre groupe facebook qui
a déjà plus de trente mille personnes
qui l'ont fait si vous avez des
questions écrivez nous par courriel
salut
[Musique]